we want to give our money to American
farmers and in a recession why are we
continuing to hand it to Canadians
arguably no band is dumber in the United
States than the ban on growing
industrial hemp we can import him for
our products you can find it in the
Obama campaign store you can see it in
dr. bronner's magic soaps you just can't
grow it in the United States reasontv
welcomes David bronner head of dr.
bronner's magic soaps David you want to
tell us about your arrest in June for
protesting in front of the White House
so my protest in front of the White
House I locked myself in a cage with
industrial hemp plants which I harvested
in pressing the oil I was in there for
three hours lecturing police and in the
crowd we want to give our money to
American farmers and in a recession why
are we continuing to hand it to
Canadians what's the biggest negative
effect of not being able to grow him
domestically well I mean in economically
it's like I mean we have the world's
largest consumer market for hemp seed
and fiber products so American farmers
are being systematically cut out of this
you know growth market hemp is replacing
fiberglass is a compression as a
composite material with polypropylene so
all the German automobiles on the road
today are basically made with industrial
hemp paneling and in the inner door
panel what does it take what are the
obstacles to getting industrial hemp
grown domestically the obstacles is the
you know the drug war complex I mean
basically these drug warriors see
anything that threatens cannabis
prohibition which is a house of cards
you know whether it's industrial medical
you know anything that threatens the
rhetoric that cannabis is a plant with
roots in hell with no redeeming value
whatsoever it has no industrial
application no medical value no
spiritual note no nothing and for them
anything that threatens that is you know
has to be resisted and you know all out
but however senator Wyden of Oregon and
Senator Rand Paul of Kentucky have just
introduced an industrial hemp farming
bill in the Senate we feel like this is
you know we can really lobby and finally
get Congress to direct a DEA from its
willful misinterpretation of policy do
you think that the only way we're going
to get domestically grown industrial
hemp is if we also legalized marijuana
or
like their fates intertwined ultimately
yes I mean it's unfortunate to an extent
I mean we're going to still go full on
pushing industrial hemp only but clearly
cannabis prohibition in general is
absurd and is teetering the cultures in
a large shift we've we've given $50,000
of Colorado effort 50,000 of the
Washington effort you know we definitely
see as you know can I bishop cannabis
prohibition fails across the board like
obviously industrial hemp farming will
finally be free I mean it's ridiculous
that that's the way it has to be but you
know apparently that's the way it has to
be thank you David bronner of dr.
bronner's magic soaps I'm Mike Riggs
mrs. recent TV